Good morning John!
It is that magical time of year
between the time when we give gifts and the time when we celebrate the new year.
It's magical in that I don't have anything that I'm supposed to be doing.
I don't know how! And I kinda just wanna go back to work.
Which, maybe I'm a workaholic or maybe I just have a really great job.
Yeah, this is the one time of the year when I get to decide for myself what I wanna do.
So that's sledding
[music] [Hank's voice] huaaaagh!
[music continues]
[Hank] Aaaaau this was a bad idea!
[Hank, offscreen] there's a bush. Right towards the bush!
[music]
And answering science questions on Tumblr.
Also playing video games, eating fried egg sandwiches, cuddling,
But mostly answering science questions on Tumblr.
It turns out that it is just one of my favorite things in the world to do and if you haven't seen my Tumblr asks,
Here are some of the fascinating things about the world that I have learned due to people asking me questions on Tumblr.
There is a kidney.
that has been in three different people.
The person who donated it, she donated it to her brother,
and then he couldn't use it, it didn't work, for whatever reason
so they took it out and they were like, "So, this is yours now,
you have rights over this thing,
what should we-- can we put it in another person or should we throw it away?"
and he was like, "Put it in another per--" but I think it's fascinating that bec-- like, the MOMENT it entered his body cavity,
it was his. And he got to decide.
Not his sister, who was the original owner of the kidney,
And not the medical establishment, who had the kidney and put it inside of him,
But him, the guy.
And he was like, "Yeah give it to somebody else." And they did.
So that kidney has been in three different people.
Sperm whales undergo massive changes in pressure.
like, if you take deep sea fish up to not-deep-sea locations, they explode.
And if you take fish from the top of the ocean and bring them to the bottom, then they get crushed.
But sperm whales, they go from like the top of the ocean all the way down to like 2,000 feet below the ocean.
Which is 200 atmospheres different in pressure.
And, they're mammals, so they have lungs which are filled with air, which can cause all kinds of problems
with nitrogen getting into your-- it's crazy!
How do they do this?!
When they dive, they actually collapse their own lungs,
So that that's not a problem.
And then all of the oxygen they need is stored in their blood, in their hemoglobin,
and in special oxygen-storage proteins in their muscles.
The blink of an eye. Sounds like it's fast.
and it does not take very much time, only about 300 milliseconds,
but in those 300 milliseconds, it only travels about 1 inch,
So it's actually very slow, it's like, a fifth of a mile per hour,
Slow blinking.
We have created a drug
which prevents hair from going gray.
It actually reverses the graying process.
But!
It causes diarrhea and nausea and occasionally death.
So that's not good.
But it also is good for treating leukemia.
and it costs about 90,000 dollars a year.
So. Hair dye!
We do not know, if the core of Jupiter is a liquid or a solid.
It is very hot, but also under tremendous amounts of pressure.
In fact, if Jupiter was just 10 times bigger, there would be so much pressure,
that there would be sustainable fusion reactions going on inside of it
and we would live in a binary star system.
My all-time favorite question though, that has been asked of me on Tumblr is:
"If I weigh 99 pounds and I eat 1 pound of nachos, does that mean I am 1% nacho?"
This question turns out to be so complicated that I cannot answer it in this video.
We may do an entire episode of SciShow on it.
It's fascinating.
I hope you enjoyed these fascinating science facts that I have learned,
I love the world, and I love weird, exciting interesting questions about the world,
So thank you to people on Tumblr for doing this, and yes,
I do know that now I'm going to get like, way more asks than I can answer.
So, sorry, I probably won't be able to answer your asks.
But I am going on Reddit right now to do an AMA.
If you would like to join me, you can ask me anything.
I just feel like answer-y question-y today, though my wrist is already starting to hurt.
From the typing. So. Not from the video games, I promise.
John, I hope that this week of being able to do whatever you want is-- probably not, because you have kids
so, you're probably doing whatever they want.
That sounds like less fun.
But I'm sure you're enjoying it nonetheless, and I'll see you on Tuesday.
[Michael Aranda] Today I'm here with Matthew Gaydos, and Hank Green [Hank] Hey! [Michael] and Katherine Green
And we are sliding on things down the snow.